this podcast is brought to you by Helix
sleep
night after night two people lay in the
same bed but when it comes to buying a
new mattress only one gets their way
that is until now introducing Helix
sleep you buy your mattress online and
it's customized for both of you that's
right each side of the bed for hundreds
of dollars instead of thousands and our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com Joey
that's h-e-l-i-x sleep.com slash Joey
and you get 50 off of your first order
that's 50 off of your order Helix
sleep.com slash Joey helix sleep.com
and the show is brought to you by
anna.com go to onit.com and use code
word church to get 10 off all of their
great optimization products I was lucky
enough to get some new of their Dolce
way protein I'm gonna try that out
letting you know how it is it's anna.com
code word church
you bad [__]
kick that horse Lee
oh [__]
oh [__] it's pedophile night here
tonight oh [__]
here we go [__] here we go here
we go Lisa yeah in the [__]
house oh [__] it's a Monday night
[__] oh
it is close to midnight in some places
something evils [__] lurking you get
an eight ball
you bump into some strange chick with a
missing eyeball and an eye patch after a
couple bumps you're like [__] it
you try to scream
but you say [__] it this chick is
terrifying me
will she suck my dick with the eye patch
oh [__]
disgusting
let me tell you something all right
let me tell you how [__] the FBI is
as dumb as they come it took him a month
to crack the [__] phone meanwhile
there's a [__] kid in Jersey who
could have cracked that in two [__]
days what they were saying was is that
like they could have cracked it a while
ago but it looks like it happened yeah
they're [__] lazy like they could
have done in two [__] days but let me
tell you how stupid the FBI is if I was
the FBI right now
I would dig up gravana
I would go visit gravano in the prison
I said gravano you probably got what
left on your sentence they're going to
give you parole to this age
how about when you go home you go home
that's it no chapter of the government
with Sammy the bull God he's dead
everybody's dead
we want the whole thing on Trump
oh wow yeah we want the deals we want
the payoffs how they were made who
collected the money and then you take
that to Trump and go listen we ain't
gonna tell nobody
this is between us we're friends right
the secret is between us
now anytime the FBI asks for something
Trump will have to give it to them
when he's president
it's not black man blackmail that's a
big [__] word right there
that was a bad word
it's letting you know that I know
I've always told you that's the biggest
thing when you're out there is letting
[__] know somebody's at a party
and they're talking [__] about you
right
some people go and attack that dude you
don't say nothing for [__] two years
and one night when it's you and him
alone you dropped on him and you watch
him break
and that's what happens because people
can't believe the Ascension they came
back to haunt them but not right away
but what about the model itself like
wouldn't the mom be doing the same thing
to him if he gets to be president the
mob the mob that's in now doesn't know
that was 30 [__] years ago oh his
dealings were between 80 and 85 86. so
that's over now 88 yeah that connection
died gravano took that with him yeah
they own sna construction and they have
different companies that the mob the mob
has a two percent Club okay two percent
of the profit goes to the mafia
what they do is they get 16 [__]
people companies Lee syack construction
Joey Diaz construction and we go into a
Club bidding Club so now instead of us
bidding for jobs you just get the job
for two percent so this million but any
job over two million dollars
so the concrete you got to buy from my
company now let me explain something to
you concrete per square foot
in Oklahoma I'm just making these
numbers up it's 35 a square foot again
I'm just making these numbers up I don't
want people on Twitter hit me Joey I
live in Oklahoma you don't know what the
[__] you're talking about I'm just
making these numbers up but when you
deal with sna Construction
his concrete is 82.50 a square foot
that's the mob squeeze so they take two
percent and then they [__] you on that
um and then they control different
unions let's say they have the laborers
union or the [__] Pipe Fitters unit
that's how they work now for them not to
Shake You Down you have to pay them back
you have to be in the thing I know
Trump's personality Trump didn't want to
be in the big Club Trump said [__] it
I'll make you a partner
okay and that's how now the construction
was really New York tight between that
those years when Trump was in
and the guy that ran construction if you
want to look this up at home do you have
the time and you're that much of a
[__] stiff
the guy who ran the construction in New
York was a guy by the name of Sammy the
bull gravano he was on the boss but
again being a crime family he had 18
different companies all related to the
construction field
glass piping architecture electrical
electrical because if you so now Lee
syat was only getting one job every
three months
the least I had
is fighting for his life he's bidding
these [__] okey-doke jobs
one day the Mind believes cyan says wait
a second
he gets down he starts writing notes and
he comes up with
even if I give half of my Prophet that
these inflated prices I make money
so instead of getting two jobs a year I
get six jobs a year and I split the
profits
I'm busy all year I still make more
money than I was ever making before let
me approach Sammy the bull make him a
partner
what now no you come to me how about I
give you 40 of my company make you a
partner give you a taste give you a tax
return
make you VP of uh whatever give me like
a fake [__] job you follow me like
the one Tony had him yeah garbage place
right there you go
so now when when Sam Sammy the bull was
a genius because now when he gets he's
got a taste of all those companies
plus he was getting partners and he was
shooting them
and then taking the whole company from
him how could he pull that more than
once like I feel like after the second
time they'd be like maybe we shouldn't
be partners started disappearing all his
mate DB the Bernardo the guy in Staten
Island all his brother-in-law
he killed his wife's brother Doug
why because
he was causing a lot of [__] problems
but to just keep this on Trump that's
how crazy like I'm looking at this world
news tonight because Trump's a [__]
genius okay Trump's got so much money
that he's just paying listen
you ever see your [__] Law and Order
yeah when I go lisayat was involved in
gay Point that's irrelevant uh I object
I'm sustained
that sustained don't mean dick because
the jewelry heard that right yeah okay
so what he's doing is he's blowing up
little fires and all these [__]
little magazines that every that you
read while you're online at the
supermarket those what do you call those
things you know time not time but like
the tablets tabloids I'm sorry I don't
know I forgot the words sometimes I
smoke dope but then so so he lights
fires I'm coming to you and say listen
what if I gave you what if
what if
I gave you a picture a Ted Cruz with a
blunt and two hundred thousand dollars
what if
I could [__] Photoshop that I can
meme that don't they don't but they take
pictures yeah they could do anybody
else's head now these college or even
even if he just just puts it out there
on like Fox News or any any TV thing if
he just said well you know I heard Ted
Cruz likes to play with monkeys I don't
know what anything just the fact that he
said it that's it it's out there now
you're waiting for your groceries and
you look up and boom Ted Cruz involved
in the sex scandal
no what happens because he has casinos
in Vegas and Atlantic City the mop has
to be involved in casinos right wow I
know you don't know he made them
corporate okay see once the corporations
took over the casinos
that made it a little tougher for that
Skip and they know it but they get taken
care of in other ways which I don't
really know I really don't know you know
you hear all these rumors the mob has
gone from Vegas I don't know
I don't know I don't know none of that
[__] I don't know who's exists anymore I
don't know what the [__] goes on but I
do know that I was watching that tonight
and I'm like Trump is such a swindler
that's some he's gonna win but somebody
should Swindle him and you know who
could Swindle him the NBN
the FBI can Swindle him and have their
[__] way with them the president is a
vice president whoever runs the FBI can
get whatever he wants and [__]
support the next four or five or six
eight years oh my God yeah I mean if he
does that to him which is crazy to think
about
strong arming the president whatever
whatever you want to call it that's it
Hey listen they couldn't strong on
Canada they shot him in the [__] head
they blew his [__] brain up where the
[__] did that where the [__] did that
okay
that's
it gets scarier and scarier like the
more I see okay I'm sure this has been
going on forever but I was just too
young and naive to see it but like the
more and more you see was like the
political system and the way it works
like people don't pay attention to the
political system they think because they
watch CNN politics they know what
politics really are and they don't
they don't they don't why do I give why
do I give Jeb Bush 200 000 my earned
money because I have something I want to
do there's something I want to do I want
to Zone that neighborhood I want to do
something
so it's a dirty [__] business right I
think that's a job like they go through
the donor list at a certain point after
they get elected like okay well we have
to pay off these amount over a hundred
thousand dollars they have to pay off
Neighbors in this business in this
[__] presidential debate okay with
all this whatever it's called and I come
to a presidential guy a candidate let's
call him
and I say them listen
over the years I've been accused of
doing a lot of things
but I'm really a hot dog sale
I have 35 hot dog spans all across the
country
have a name and I make millions of
dollars a years selling hot dogs yes Mr
Diaz sounds hot though
but my real business is drugs let's just
say
let's say I make 20 million dollars a
year
15 million dollars a year three million
cash to me is nothing
I would donate it to a presidential
debate whatever the [__] a presidential
candidate because I know that in the
future I want to expand my business
I want to expand my business I want to
go to Mexico I want to go to Europe I
want to expand my business and double
that if I get caught in the presidential
but I need something
I would do you know let's just see these
are the things you have to assume
they're doing it that money is coming
from somewhere when a medical supply
company I'm not a medical supply company
Pharmacy
with a new pill and they're having a
tough time with the FDA they know Lee
Syed is a senator of [__] Wisconsin
he's tight with the vice president of
the FDA I'll give 500 000 to your
donation a million dollars because I
know you're gonna but there's a once I
go to your fundraiser
that's why I'm not whisper in your ear
what I need from you and then if you say
no you're not going to get that money
again what you need what you need
especially that type of those type of
digits listen I went to get a nose spray
the other day was eighty dollars oh yeah
prescription yeah 80 but I went today to
get a pill and it was a dollar sixteen
so you never [__] know they get you
somewhere or the other they really do
and and now it's getting to the point
where like CVS right I can't get like
whenever I get sick here I go to the
clinic because you can't get a doctor's
appointment within like two weeks I have
like pretty decent insurance
so I'm paying CVS to go to the clinic
I'm paying CVS for the pills and it's so
they have all they they're making all
the money like that's it's crazy what we
allow
hey for 35 hours when I was growing up a
doctor come to your house and give you a
shot of penicillin the prescription
right and now I have to wait two weeks
even though I have insurance and they
raise your they raise my insurance every
year
it's [__] crazy it's just and that's
why I think Bernie Sanders is so popular
I don't really know like I know what
he's talking about I don't know if it's
gonna if because no matter who you talk
to either the hate Trump or the hate
Sanders so you don't know who's what's
real
but I can see that I'm paying 350 right
now for insurance I can't really use
yeah there's people I'm listening to a
podcast I can't imagine it if you don't
have insurance today you're getting
[__] raped and it's tough either way
you're getting [__] in the ass but
it's
you gotta have the insurance I went for
years without insurance how I don't
[__] know
how I do not [__] know I went to like
35 with no insurance just living on the
edge until I joined static I didn't have
insurance
3 6 19 20 years ago
so I was 33 years old 34 years old and I
got [__] insurance
so what would you do if you got sick I
toughed It Off
I went to the pharmacy like everybody
else saying Hell vitamin C
if it was one time I went to the
hospital for my throat I got a throat
infection
in Colorado that's never come up on my
[__] uh credit report really what the
hell happened to 200 300 one time I had
an abscess and a tooth I went to
Cedar Memorial whatever on Beverly I
never heard of that bill either they
probably figured out I had sack
insurance and
that's crazy so this weekend I went to
Paducah yeah I went to Paducah
with my uh wife and the baby and uh they
had a great time and I was sitting there
for a little while you know and I was
sitting outside looking at the horses
and all this they have horses oh yeah my
[__] brother-in-law's got three
horses right there in the yard
the yard is the size of this [__]
neighborhood
I got a three bedroom house with the
side with a barn
a [__] camper and then three horses
fenced off
just it's got to be a couple football
fields gee that must have been fun for
myself oh mercy hasn't [__] stopped
running but
I was sitting there
I thought of a friend of mine that I
hadn't spoken to in a long [__] time
since 1993 I just thought of
and I see his brother on Facebook
all the time and there was rumors
growing up you know later on
but I realized while I was sitting there
how much I love this kid growing up like
it was just he was just a dynamite fun
kid
his name was Fernie and Timmy Holloway's
probably listening right now Fernie was
one of these kids
that it was to me
like his tolerance
was through the roof no way he's more
tolerant than you oh
his tolerance was through the roof with
everything
with everything
whatever he did he did double
from his gambling to his weight lifting
I mean he was a kid that had a [__]
body like an Adonis his shoulders were
huge growing up
we always knew each other since the
seventh eighth grade from playing
basketball
but we didn't talk we just waved at each
other and hey what's up then we became
freshmen together
and we'd talk at parties and he always
showed up with like you know if you had
a ten dollar bag
he always had a twenty dollar bag was he
a rich kid no his father had a
restaurant Edgewater New Jersey that was
called hmb diner right by where they
shot Copland it was right over there
was a tremendous little [__] greasy
spoon but he made the best pork
sandwiches on a timebread with hot sauce
and pickles
fresh Cuban [__] pork with an Italian
bread with Swiss cheese and [__] hot
sauce pork and swiss cheese good googly
moogly good googly moogly and he'd melt
the Swiss cheese over the [__] bread
you have no idea my friend but Fernie
and me became tight it was me Fernie
Roger and this kid by the name of Glenn
Conte AKA stinky
and we became a unit November of 81.
we all hung out from time to time but
then we started getting together
Fernie was one of the first guys that
really had a car
like that his father just gave him the
car and it had a hole in the back seat
he put a piece of metal on that but when
he would drive the car the metal would
move
Glenn had his mother's car from time to
time and Roger
he had his father's car he would borrow
from time to time but Fernie was always
the ride
and whenever Fernie would drive he would
drive and he cursed people and he called
people prick he had a great prick thing
and
we hung out tight he always supported me
he always had my back you know no matter
what he was very quiet I got him beat up
one time in a barn Hoboken called
Gennaro's
what do you mean you got him beat up I
grabbed the girl's ass I went when I
played for St Michael's she was a
cheerleader the Cuban girl and she was
standing in front of me watching the
band and I was next to Fernie and I
reached over and grabbed her ass it was
one of these reaches like with my right
hand so I had to cross three people
so when she turned around Fernie had a
stupid look on his face with glasses he
was just as high as I was and she turned
around he was drinking an Alabama
Slammer with a white shirt on
and she turned around and smacked him in
the face and the
the the the drink went all over his
shirt and his glasses fell off everybody
knew he was blind without his glasses
but
one of the lens fell out of his glasses
so when they got stepped on she was
kicking them and he was looking for his
glasses she got beat up by he got beat
up by the girl you beat up by the girl
what [__] howling as a kid you didn't
help him out no you got beat up by a
girl what do you want to do choke the
[__] girl girl
he took your Beating he took them he
took the beat to me like a [__]
Soldier
didn't even know why he was getting hit
no he was half [__] he just got up
put his glasses back on and the one once
was broken and he had a big red stain on
this [__] white shirt
and that was the end of that tune
oh my God I was [__] howling but I
robbed that jewelry store
well I was in Florida on The Hideout
we were
you know talking on the phone
we would talk on the phone talk on the
phone talk on the phone being fair
enough for some reason I always talk to
Fernie how can you be on The Hideout and
talking on the phone because the cops
weren't really tapping phones in those
days for some guy who robbed the jewelry
store Fernie one thing I know about Fern
is that Fernie didn't talk
probably didn't talk unless it was us
like Fernie never talked like if Fernie
in those days came in the room right now
Fernie would actually just talk to me he
wouldn't talk to you
he wouldn't even pay attention he
wouldn't acknowledge he wouldn't even
acknowledge her I said not because he
was rude but that was funny like he
didn't know you and he didn't want to
know you
know whatever he had enough friends he'd
show up sit down and whip out a bag of
weed that could kill a mule
so I come back from Florida on the
Highland and on the phone call the night
before he tells me he goes hey man I
talked to my mother you could stay here
with me
and at that time my soul
was gone
like I was gone like I I had no I didn't
claim responsibility for what my actions
roughly
19. okay
just
totally out of control the world owed me
a [__] thing I was angry at the world
and I did what the [__] I wanted until I
either caught a beating I was going to
go to jail or whatever
and this kid opens up his home to me
the same man [__] all that [__] we got
the basement we could bring [__]
no bill no I got my weights down there
we got a bathroom you could shower
upstairs
but besides that everything's downstairs
you could my mother's never home so you
could shower up there in the daytime if
you need to take a shower but besides
that we got the whole downstairs they
never come down here
and it was it that's that's all we
needed we were smoking dope downstairs
we were doing blowing downstairs
we wealth downstairs his parents never
ones were like hey guys well one night
he ate a [__] Quaalude we got four
Quaaludes
and I told him just he won he ate two
and he went in the shower we're
downstairs drinking beers [__]
smoking reef and his father came down he
goes bro you gotta go upstairs Freddie's
asleep in the shower
we went upstairs he was in the shower on
two loads passed out with his socks on
we had to take him out of the shower
they're like what happened to him we
don't know he's saying he was dying he
was [__] up
his father that [__] came
downstairs did like three lines and it
was like nothing happened
we got in the car we had to go see Pat
Benatar I never forget that and he kept
some guy parked too close to him
like they gave him an inch in the front
and they're coming back I'll never
forget this
and he's putting the car reverse boom
putting the Kaboom boom boom and at that
time it's me I'm in the back seat no I'm
in the side seat and Roger Holloway is
in the back seat I'm gonna forget this
like it was yesterday
and he's doing this for two minutes boom
boom boom he's taught you know he's
turning the wheel but every time he
makes a thing he hits one of the [__]
cars
and finally Roger Ben this other because
he'll be playing bumper cars I never
forget you know it was something [__]
every night with him
but he was my brother he had my he had
my back
he let me oh [__] oh [__] he had my back
man this guy let me move into his
[__] basement
Felicia Michaels in the house come over
and sit down my love right over here
so this guy [__] let me live with him
and it was just Felicia really get ready
for this yes because it was two 19 year
old boys
we had no Direction he was working at
his father's restaurant in Edgewater
and when as soon as I got back it took
me about a week to get a job I got a job
look at you I got a job
at a [__] place that made frames for
Entenmann's cake
you ever go into a supermarket and see
Entenmann's cake yeah oh yeah and they
had the [__] stands that say you know
Anthem and gentlemen sentiment that's
what I did I was a union Entenmann cake
stand Builder that's not a bad job no it
wasn't a [__] bad job but I spent my
whole salary at that [__] Diner
because I wouldn't eat lunch at the
place so I would go there and have like
a 20-hour lunch like three pork
sandwiches me and stinking and then they
hooked us up this whole time I'm living
with Fern and give them like 50 a week
and would drive into his restaurant at
five in the morning listen I'll never
forget Dada went to listen to The Nasty
Girl Nasty Girl do you think I'm dancing
in the car and [__] 319-year-old jerk
offs
jerk-offs
and uh
he was what do you like I was just
telling Lee he was one of those people
he didn't smoke pot Felicia like if you
bought a ten dollar bag he would buy a
25 bang and smoke the whole thing in
high school
he was
I don't know all those ADHD terms today
80d
he was half [__] he wasn't add
autistic no he had that [__]
he had that [__] that
he always had to do double of what you
did
we always thought Fernie would die
like I always later on said I wonder
what Fernie is
and then I heard he went to a party at
my friend's house like we all know this
guy like it's like me going to your
house with you with your kids there your
girlfriend's day going can I use your
bathroom
20 minutes you like he's been in that
bathroom a long [__] time
40 minutes you're gonna knock on the
door
my friend knocked on the door he didn't
hit on he kicked the door open Fernie
had the strap on his arm
this is like you catching me at your
house this is like you know he called me
in Colorado because I tell you what
happened last night I [__] time for
her here in my bathroom shooting heroin
at five in the [__] morning
I chased him he ran away you know leave
me alone and that was the last we really
heard of
that was it but what happened was I was
living with him
and we had gone through like you know we
hooked up in October and I got to tell
you guys it was a three-month party
like him and I went to work at five but
we were out till two
every night every night there was a bar
right across the street so we could park
the car and walk so worst case scenario
we would go into the city not to blow we
go in and get reefer park the car smoke
a joint and then we crossed the street
it was the Midtown Lounge the silver fox
the guy was they called him the Silver
Fox it was like 70s to be in there
picking up chicks and [__] we going
there
we it was like a three month tear
finally in December I tapped out we were
like I can't do this I got a job in a
lumber yard
I lived with him the whole time I got
arrested at that [__] lumber yard for
possession of stolen
tools he never said nothing to me he was
my roommate never judge me never
questioned me or took me out for a drink
[__] it we'll beat the K I mean he was
just a great guy but like I was living
with him and I was doing some wild [__]
and I was 19.
I was straying out of the neighborhood
and doing wild [__] which meant somebody
was gonna catch me and one night I tried
to break into a bookie's house
and I cut my hand with the barbed wire
and I had a cross that was I robbed that
guy's house on 57th Street I had to run
to 68th Street it doesn't seem like a
lot but I had to cross like eight
Avenues
when I got to his block the cops were
coming down the block with the light and
I had to hide under a car and I'm like
if I want to be friends with this guy
I gotta I gotta move out of his house
because something's gonna happen and
this house is gonna get shot up I was
doing some crazy [__] I was [__] with
some Cubans in Union City
that was when they were bringing cocaine
up and they had apartments and I would
break into the apartments I knew I was
going to get in trouble
and a friend of mine came up to me
because I want to go to Colorado and I I
thought about it and I said okay and I
didn't have the heart to tell Fernie I
was leaving
like I never had the heart to call set
them down and go for any I'm leaving so
while he was at work
I packed my stuff and I wrote a letter
and left the phone like that's how much
I love Fernie I was a confused kid I
didn't really know
I left after about a month I called him
we were friends but I could see that we
weren't the friends that we were like
but then I came back and we would then
we would tight again then he got
involved in gambling then he hit
somebody with the car
and he picked me up two days later after
he hit the dude with the car
and that was the first time somebody hit
somebody with a car and told me a story
and I actually pissed my pants
that's how funny like that's how crazy
he was he was smoking a joint and you
know when you cut through a gas station
instead of waiting for the red light oh
yeah he cut to the gas station hit the
sidewalk
the ash fell on his shirt and while he
was going like this there was a guy
waiting for the [__] bus
and he clipped the dude
and he got out of the car and if you
know Fernie like if you know Fernie when
he was telling me this I know he ain't
lying to me I knew him
he said he told the dude I go funny what
happened he goes I ain't thinking out of
the car
you know he was a little stars I didn't
want to wait for the cops he goes I was
running late for work so I told him to
either get up
or do something because I got to get to
work
took off
and he got hold of that night and he was
in the shower and the cops [__]
ripped him out of the shower beat him up
oh my God but again
by this time we were 20 maybe 21 Maybe
maybe now
in those days you watch vinyl he say if
you watch vinyl they all have little
glass
with a thing and you now once it got
Advanced a chain with a spoon came on
that thing
so you would take the cap off
and do little bumps now in those days I
could lie to you and tell you I did
eight balls no I didn't I always had one
of those things
not Fernie
Fernie would drive around with a quarter
round to blow
but here's what got crazy he would cut
his own blow
so he would buy
a [__]
ate the Coke and he would cut it three
and a half to three and a half to dilute
it and he would he would cut it till it
was like [__] speckled
like you weren't even getting high and
he'd sit in his car with like the Ace of
Spades and talk to you for like 20
minutes and he just keep doing bump he
was over what's that OCD he did
everything more like washing his hands a
lot like that like he did like again you
know people do and they put it down they
talk to you not fairly oh no he had to
have the mirror his own mirror
and he would just do [__] monsters
every minute on the minute
you would look at me go when is this
gonna [__]
so what happened to him
so
83 84 boom I go to Colorado I got
arrested
I come back to Jersey in 91 92 I'm
looking for Fernie no Fernie
I come back in 93 after I get divorced
no Fernie nobody's seeing Fernie his
mother still lives there she drives the
school bus she Parks the bus in front of
the house
there's no Facebook there's no Twitter
do you know my friend Timmy Holloway's
brother invites into his house to dinner
in Jersey City
I think the bus and I have to do a
transfer and I get off and I start
walking a little bit
and who do I bump into the [__]
street corner but Fernie with some broad
he gives me a hug I hugged him he goes I
heard you doing comedy Now
I said I'm trying man it's [__] hard
he goes let me come see you one night
and in that whole thing the girl looks
at him and goes is this the kid you told
me about
oh
and he gave me some number and I called
him like 10 times you never returned my
call
do you regret just leaving the letter
what do you think that might have been
it always till this [__] there regret
leaving that goddamn letter here's my
brother
he wouldn't have given a [__] if I would
have told him the truth he would like
you knew what I was crazy
so what did he say in the letter then I
love them
so they had to leave that 20 people were
looking for me
that I would have loan shark ten
thousand dollars and I needed some
[__] space before I got killed I
didn't want to bring it into his house
and do like you wish you had just said
that to him yeah yeah
I wish I would have said it tone well
why do you think he never answered the
phone or contacted you back
well you know if if he would have
understood why I didn't I think by that
time he was gone
today he has HIV from Human Herald
I heard this and I looked at the
pictures on Facebook
and I was like yeah he's
yeah he's he's very hidden nobody's ever
seen him no more reunions no nothing
so over the weekend I'm in Paducah
and I'm sitting there giggling over one
of the stupid [__] escapades like
just a thought came into me how he used
to [__] the skinny girl I saw at the
airport it looked like the girl
and I said oh my God that girl was
really pretty but she was really bony
and he says Hey fine she don't have a
[__]
and he goes she got it in there
somewhere it's good
he was always when I robbed the [__]
janitor and I had the epileptic pills
everybody was mad at me for giving them
epileptic pills like people were like
Joey you're my friend you gave me those
pills
you know what friend he told me
those [__] pills were good man you
got to get me some more of those he was
popping those and walking around and
driving people were sleeping for three
days and like he was one of those guys
like even the epileptic pills didn't
affect them yeah like he was one of
those [__] dudes
and I already got the heroin and stuff
so to make a long story short I'm
sitting here watching Mercy running
around
and he would get those thoughts like
what type of friends will they have
growing up
and for some reason I thought about my
friends I thought about Fernie
and last night I come home and I'm on
Facebook
and who pops up on Facebook
but funny
he added you as a friend no no no I got
a picture of Fernie his brother oh okay
so I went to the brother's page
in the corner
is Fernie and he's bald
and he's like he's got he still has to
he had [__] shoulders
that's the guy who taught me how to do
it behind the necks
he was behind the neck of 185 and he
goes you could do it and he would do 165
his neck was started here and it went
here and his waist was like this women
would jump on this guy is that the
picture you used to have in your old
office no no that's Rego this was
another kid that was taller his waist
was like this he was built like this no
steroids just push-ups Stakes those pork
sandwiches no heavy weight he believed
in heavy weight
so I get home last night I see this
[__] picture
against everything I got I said you know
what
I clicked onto the message thing and I
wrote after 20 years
I still think about you
I put send
and I said this motherfucker's gonna see
this and never say nothing to me I wake
up this morning there's one single
message
didn't even expect it to be him I always
wake up with a few messes and if I click
on
open it up
and he wrote
I think of you too
I said I could open this conversation up
or leave it here
I go I'm Gonna Leave it right here
let's Let It stew because this kid was
my [__] dog dog dog dog
funny Felicia off the cuff like [__]
funny like the [__] he would say
just retired just [__] funny
can I ask how come you just let it lay
it why
that crew never recovered
two out of the four became Christian
guys you know uh the guy that says [__]
in the morning born again not born again
no one became uh whatever the dude the
good looking dude in Houston with the
church
Joel Osteen the UPS one and the other
one Roger
also became a born-again Christian
that's how deep those times were like
what we were thinking and what we were
doing was not what 18 year olds did
it wasn't what 18 year olds did you know
and it was just a heart and Fernie at
that time
he had a gambling addiction
again
we're batting 40 timers you know the 40
timer is 200 bucks
me and you together who do you like
tonight you like the next let's bet the
next one's for the 200 time
let's put a 40 time first time he comes
to me he goes
what are you guys always talking about
you gamble really how much you gamble
we're like wow so he started doing math
after 10 minutes he goes what if
I put down a thousand dollar poly
does that the first time
nobody does that
that's when you bet two teams and they
both have to win
I was living with him I'm in the
basement across from him in the bed and
he's telling me this [__] and under his
bed he's got a jar filled with 150s
and he goes if I lose I get cover this
he goes so what do I do I go call my
friends that
a thousand time parlay Seattle and
somebody else what is that win
foreign
causing it the first game wins out right
the second game
27 nothing at halftime
we both smoke a joint we go to bed that
kind of giggle in the way [__] them
we both wake up Seattle comes back and
beats 28-27 he wins a thousand bucks
my friend's dad calls him back and he
goes if you want to come pick up the
money
he goes get dressed let's go pick up the
money let's go out to the best dinner
we've ever had
we got a peek at least email this is the
spot Jack [__] Waiters with the
[__] suits white people fought leave
New Jersey overlooking the Hudson people
kissing class wines I never saw that
before in my life all that [__] I go in
there I used to go in there on a little
dates and with friends at the lobster
Friday Outlaw dish
that's even more of a reason again
Lobster fried Diablo they brought you a
dish shaped like a [__] fish Felicia
and Pasta in the middle then all around
it had clams and muscles and on the top
was a [__] lobster tail with four
huge [__] prawns Felicia with red
spicy sauce with a big loaf of bread
with butter come on Felicia
tremendously going yeah he [__]
devours his plate
he's thirsty and he drinks the finger
boat
[Laughter]
picked up the [__] finger ball and
drink like nothing like nothing
and after that he wanted a gambling Fair
he was up sixty thousand dollars
under his bed yeah 18 years old wow and
he lost it all on the Super Bowl Plus
30.
and that cracked him and the book he
made him pay
so he had to pay every week
300 400 every week he paid the guy so he
owed him 800 he totally got to go [__]
himself
and that cracked him he never watched
Sports again
never
ever not even as a joke
when I bumped until 93 I go you watch
sports again he goes never again
he wouldn't even watch never
yeah that's that's crazy and back then
back then when two dollars yeah when the
dollar was worth twice the amount it's
worth now tremendous amount of money man
Killer Bees against the Redskins
that was the Superbowl he lost his ass
on
and he became a different person
like after that at 18 he became he had
to get a job at a gas station from four
to twelve and then he worked at his
father's restaurant from six before
so he only slept
on Saturday and Sunday
and he did that for eight months until
he paid the 30 or 40 Grand North
did his parents know that that had
happened you gotta go to his parents and
borrow 20 from them and it was ugly wow
so
you're happy with how your conversation
like that's why you don't really wanna
go for it like it was horrible that's
all I needed
if I if you knew this kid
if I engage him right now I might
I'm just gonna leave it there
that's as good as it gets in my world
for men
what are you supposed to do when you
lose friends like I have that friend who
I went to his wedding in Vermont he was
my my best friend in high school and I
didn't have like a bunch of friends he
was my like my best friend and he for
the past couple months you won't answer
my call I don't know what to do people
get married and people change you don't
know what it's like well I just had a
friendship that kind
that kind of someone who is very was
very close to me and
I think people
don't understand that friendships just
like relationships aren't meant to be
forever that doesn't mean they have any
less value you know I think sometimes uh
people in your life for a certain period
of time to bring Clarity to that time
but but when you have children you don't
teach children or we don't teach each
other that it's okay if you're not
friends anymore but but maybe we should
teach them how to disengage a friendship
you know well
I have a different frame myself like
when I didn't talk to you for a while I
still loved you yeah we were just making
each other yeah that was completely I
didn't want to lose yourself we're kind
of mad at each other yeah but I still
loved you after I came to my senses I
really did Mission I miss all my friends
yeah I miss all my friends like well
Chuck and mcbrain I miss like it's
basketball yeah
I'm the best one I thought about
checking [__] mcbrain
I got a [__] stupid games that me and
that [__] [__] go to now he's a
basketball coach at Ramapo or whatever
you know and just we were talking about
college basketball last week and now the
players I used to write to coaches
and uh I didn't lose Chucky
we grew apart
and we connected not even on Facebook he
hunted me down and
today we talk every 90 days you know I
know he's busy with college but we never
stopped loving each other
then there's the people you grow
away from and it's naturally somebody
gets married
somebody has a kid
somebody stops getting high yeah
somebody gets a DUI and people put
[__] blame I had something in
December that happened to me that was
just horrible I I went back East with my
family and I got those Hilton [__]
points and a week before I went and
[__] hit me up and said we either
give you a room for free one night or
we'll take a room off your tab so I
called one of my best friends in life
like hey man what are you doing next
weekend why don't you come up bring the
wife see the baby go get some Chinese
food we'll smoke a couple joints
and he goes that's not a bad idea This
is 40 [__] years Felicia you know he
spent Millions on me this kid I call him
back and come up we're going to dinner
in one of the conversations he calls me
back and he goes hey man I'm thinking of
bringing my kids I go dog I'm bringing a
kid I'm not calling you to see the kids
I'm calling to see you he goes all right
I'll call you tomorrow he didn't call me
back yeah
I was like I opened my [__] mouth I
said something about the kids I really
don't like his girlfriend's boyfriend
maybe I was in the [__]
[__] and she's been dating this
creepy [__] since she's like 17
showing up in my comedy shows with him
and eats me a lot I'm one of those dude
I'm saying like I'm that Uncle like just
and I can't say nothing and I'm like
like he was telling me he lives at the
house with him
that sent me into a [__] Loop like I
was like this is you let this guy live
under the same roof with her in your
[__] house
like this isn't the guy I know but I
guess you make exceptions for your
daughters
you know I guess you say this is the guy
that she likes and she wants so I said
it as a joke it was true I wanted to see
him his niece sent me a picture of me
and him in high school hugging
what the [__] wouldn't it be nice so for
three months I was like there goes 40
years
he called me two weeks ago and he goes
he's still mad at me I'm not mad at you
and she said I could never be mad at him
never after all we went through I don't
get you can't come up just call me but
he said I was embarrassed folks
I got [__] going on with my life you
don't know about okay I accepted now
we've been talking he's taking a flying
off the Black Sabbath at the Hollywood
Bowl and doing ass with me the whole
thing that makes me feel good like that
if we could reconnect I feel bad like I
didn't get him a gift for his wedding
but I like but you flew out that was a
genome and a tuxedo and your shoes
no no I'm I'm close with his with his
wife and I was thinking honestly you
because I was thinking about maybe
calling his wife because we're close
because I don't want to go around
somebody no call listen what's going on
they haven't called me back maybe
there's something going on I don't know
man maybe this could have a [__]
heart attack he's in the hospital room
and she's watching them everything maybe
his father's sick you don't [__] know
these things right so just call the wife
and go hey I don't mean to pry but I've
been calling for three months nobody
calls me back is everything okay is
there anything I could do but then
here's the thing like I had a friend and
I'm not gonna name names that we were
super super close and then I could tell
you know when someone starts shining you
you can [__] tell right what's shiny
do you know when someone's like not like
kind of dodging you but they're not
really come when you do hang out you can
feel the energies kind of [__] up
what did they oh no but then uh and then
I said to this person like what's up and
and then she had like this whole [__]
list of [__] that I had done over like
three or four months and and it was like
you have a [__] list you have a list
you know and some of it was like because
I teased her about uh her outfit once
but it was like oh you're so adorable in
that outfit and then she got upset at
that and then she got mad because I said
something about her friend that wrote
thank you cards made her daughter learn
how to write like stupid [__] like that
and then she got this is when I was like
okay uh I have to disengage for a while
she got upset because uh my son and me
were watching Comedy Central and on
Comedy Central someone said oh that's a
basic [__] but as we were watching it
in the kitchen I was actually on
match.com but I had my computer uh up
you know my laptop where he couldn't
sales on Match.com and he goes mom
what's a basic [__] and I turned the
computer around I go all these guys on
match.com basic [__] right and we
laughed so hard so I tell my friend that
and then she's like I was so offended
that you and your son had that
conversation you told me that story and
I'm like are you [__] kidding
yeah yeah like why what the [__] is that
about and when someone starts making a
list it's like [__] that did you have
like a written down list she never
written down list but when I was like
what's going on I feel like there's this
weirdness and I had to kind of corner
her and then she's like well it's this
this and this and then she goes let's
make an appointment next week and we'll
talk about what our problems are with
each other and I'm like the only problem
I have is that my best friend don't like
me anymore that's the only [__]
problem I have like you have a [__]
list you know and I said to her you know
when you have a friendship there's [__]
that you say in front of your friend
that your friend gets annoyed she said
stuff in front of me like how she
doesn't have kids and how she was saying
[__] about kids on a plane like and you
no like before I had kids that you know
I used to think the same things and no
matter what someone would have told me I
would have never understood what [__]
having kids is like and so uh I said to
her well sometimes you're really [__]
mean about kids and how parents don't
take care of their kids on a plane and
and and then I get all pissed off or
like a millisecond but then I realized
you have that right to think that and
there's nothing I'm going to say that's
going to change that so who gives a [__]
I'm not mad about it let's you know who
gives a [__] you know but but some
people will like just take out of the
air little tiny things that have nothing
to do with you and then you have to
understand that friendship sometimes is
letting that person have their moment
and but that you don't have to buy into
their [__] that's not you that's him you
don't have to worry even though you miss
the friendship you don't have to carry
it around no I know but then like I feel
bad like I haven't it's really tough I
don't know when you go to college and
you come out and start working you're so
focused on all that stuff I just I
wasn't really a great friend I didn't
call that often but then again like no
one whenever I feel like that I'm like
no well I'm not like denying call I'm
not like ignoring calls from all these
people so it's a two-way street but it's
still you never want to lose someone so
I'm a [__] animal
Felicia fees and Lee and I were having a
conversation and Felicia has felt it and
Lee and I were having a conversation
I know you've had this gone you've had
this thought
comedy is a great thing to do life is
great but comedy's even better because
you really get to learn the little
things about life that while you're
suffering as a stand-up comic you're
learning things that most people won't
see about human beings
how people treat you on the road and how
you've been stuck in certain situations
as complete stranger has bailed you out
and in my world tonight I was talking to
Lee about drugs you know and we were
talking about the disgusting things I
did on blow with women
just animalistic disgusting things that
didn't make me feel any yeah
I don't know you know I'm saying like
you meet somebody they're with somebody
you give them a bump a cup next you know
you swap and spit finger over the
bathroom meanwhile the date is at the
bar
and you're sitting there and you go home
and you go what the [__] just happened
what the [__] just happened and you go
you know what this is what comedy is all
about you know what I'm saying why
question it I'm not gonna question life
in the right little things and you can't
talk about this on stage but believe it
or not
I think of all those people
still think of the stinky hot chick to
pick me up in Ogallala Nebraska
I still like I wish I knew her name so I
would have looked it up on Facebook and
thank the for the kind thing she did
in 1995 when I was a [__] starving
doing the triple run and the axle on my
car broke down
and she picked me up hitchhiking no bra
on Felicia it was like one of those
episodes of Remember The Hitchhiker on
HBO late night the guy would be
hitchhiking on some hot chick would pick
him up and suck his dick and then drop
him off and what a life you know what
I'm saying like Jesus I'm thinking about
hitchhiking this was perfect until she
started saying were you to come back to
my place
wait till my friends meet you and we all
pray together
you just threw that curveball and we
were just gonna go back and eat dinner
and have a great time and what pray she
goes well I live on the thing a commune
and we pray at night you're more than
welcome to come over and eat and spend
the night and I'm like listen
drive me to the gas station so my little
fantasy just escaped even her yeah like
you think about all these people like I
do I do and I'm an animal but when you
had those moments of being with chicks
like that and fingering them in a
bathroom and cooking them up and putting
gum in their ass whatever you're doing I
remember that story uh or the rapper in
her butt but do at the time afterwards
did you feel and I don't know if guilt
is the right word but did you feel gross
about your behavior absolutely you did
but for how long like and then that was
over and I'm being completely serious or
you know what I mean I might think of
where the [__] that came from
and I would write it off that a cocaine
at the position where I was in my life
because that that's something I would
you know listen when you're out drinking
and doing it's it's like The Comedy
Store we were discussing the other night
if you really think back about the
disgust Fest that was
you know everybody on the outside
thought it was a great time for comedy
but they really looked into the inside
it became an evil thing
yeah it was pretty gross you know and
that's that drug trend of
girlfriend at home where your friends
and wife or
you know whatever the [__] you're doing
that's not home it's fun you know why
you're doing it but then you think back
and you go she's a mom today
one night we had two [__] in the
[__] mountain and a cork up her
[__] and she's barking and [__] today
she's driving the kid to the seventh
grade like nothing you know you think
about this and you see him and you're
happy that their life worked out you
don't know how to meet the girls on
Facebook that I grew up with that were
[__] Savages and now I see him I got
a baby their life changed God bless them
like you're like I thought about all
those people Felicia whether I [__]
around with them or not if you came into
my journey God forbid you gave me a ride
or fed me or gave me a joint for the
road oh my God I still think of those
people like people who drove me to this
Trailways to get a bus you meet those
people on the road you ever get to a
town one night early
I think about one time I was doing a gig
and I had this is when I was first doing
comedy and I had a 1970 Mustang and it
was a piece of [__] and I had to drive
to do The Comedy Store and the comedy
stores at the old Dunes Hotel in Las
Vegas and I broke down in the middle of
the desert and some guy came with a
truck and gave me a ride all the way to
Vegas and I called and got my car towed
and I think about all the time like how
[__] nuts is that that I got into
some guy's truck in the middle of the
desert you know but that he did that
kindness for me you know
crazy I'm on the run
I got caught in a hotel room in San
Francisco and I didn't get arrested but
they were coming to get me I'll never
forget this they were coming to get me
and I took my ex-wife and we took a bus
to Arena
we got to Reno we couldn't even get
rolling papers at that time they were
throwing in jail for 22 [__] years so
we took a bus right back to San
Francisco
we went uh to the bus station
and the next morning we woke up and we
put on as many things as we could and
shoot
we got in the [__] car
something happened
she left the cash
at the bus station
the one from just buying all that stuff
thing weird happened
something [__] weird happened at the
bus station she went and got a soda
and put her purse down in the 800 hours
and it we had the karma coming to us
don't get me wrong it was coming to us
and we just didn't know what time here
it was cops are looking for us win a cab
to the airport
we made the cab driver turn around
take us back to the [__] bus station
we looked while it was gone
guy goes well you have a flight to catch
yeah we do she had a flight to catch
I was gonna get stuck until she went
home and got more money
so we went back to the airport and the
guy gave us his business card
which he trusted us
and she had to go back to get the front
of the jewelry that we pulled
and she called the guy he picked her up
gave her a ride to get the jewelry she
paid him the money
he drove right back to the airport a
year later
and I still think about that [__] cab
driver what most cab drivers would have
said [__] you he drove us back to SFO
and gave us a business card we could
have told him to [__] off and rip that
car up I said no we're gonna pay that
guy that [__] money
I don't give a [__] how we pay it we're
gonna pay that guy was like 55 bucks
we got the guy the [__] money I've
always felt good about doing that that's
the type of [__] that you make his day
like all right you're like what he
remembered oh my God like in those days
I was doing a lot of bad things but from
time to time I would do good things
doing that I still remember doing that
like going back and she paid the guy the
55 plus like a hundred dollar tip yeah
and he wouldn't take the tip he was like
no no no I'm embarrassed he's no you
[__] bailed us out that night you
have no idea I still think about that
guy that was 31 years ago
like what happened to the [__] dude
like I wish
I could do a Sit count while I go
looking for these [__] just
done
right like what happened to this guy
that uh
you know gave me a ride to the Improv at
that time you know when you're a feature
acting you fly in and you realize the
club is 40 [__] minutes that's a 200
camera
you basically got 30 000 in cash there's
no ATM card when I was featured there
was nothing right you have no [__]
idea how many people picked me up at the
airport for free and oh my God I think
of those people like I [__] don't
remember their names
but I remember their faces which but
also when you hear a story about someone
paying someone back like I was engaged
briefly to this guy after I was divorced
and he uh got out of nowhere
a thousand dollar check from Chelsea
Handler and apparently like 10 years
beforehand when she had just come into
town he had lent her money I don't know
what the situation was I don't know but
she when she made it on her show and
everything 10 years later how many years
later sent him the money back out of the
blue and I was never a big fan of hers
but I was like damn that's [__]
awesome that's awesome that she did that
you know make some of these [__] day
like that they
you give them faith for a day
you really give somebody faith for a day
when you make that that type of movement
when you're like hey
10 years ago you gave me 82 dollars and
you know like
until this day I try to give Ari 40
bucks he left me and he always goes I
don't give a [__]
to this day yesterday letting me 40
bucks on the road one time when am I
gonna give it back
so I I you know
you just think of all that [__] I wish I
would have written names down
I wish I would have done like a
like I would have wrote my road log down
like Road wrote down like a diary of
dates and kept it I didn't think you
know I didn't think I did have notebooks
what I wrote like the day like what I
wanted to do what I was thinking but
it was I would do it at night when I was
coked up so I couldn't even read it it
was hieroglyphics in the morning I would
catch one word and try to put the
[__] thing together you know
but I wish I would have run like Road
Diaries like and now I don't do nothing
on the road I go eat breakfast a free
breakfast I [__] talk to the guy at
the [__] front desk
again Eminem's at night I go to my room
that's it that's it I go to my room and
drink coffee I watch Law and Order
that's it I think of my [__] life on
the road now to compare it to you know
when you did a gig and stayed out and
[__] but then you were featured you
didn't even give a [__] right you just
need to come up with 20 minutes and I'm
out of that [__] yeah
so but on the friend thing
I grieve over that every day I grieve
over not talking to going conti and
Fernie and those guys
so to me just knowing that he thinks
about me from time to time that made my
day
because I I think about it and I think
about sitting down with him and maybe
having a conversation but I know that
I'm happy with that if he hits me back
on Facebook and wants to get together
come to a show which he won't
he was never one of those typing dudes I
could get him to a movie and maybe a
Chinese restaurant that was the most to
his extent they couldn't get him out
even in those days he didn't understand
you know
I would meet him for lunch or something
I just got together with another friend
that didn't talk to for maybe 10 years
and he was at a
Salvation Army he was getting his life
back together he was working on an
elevator or something like that and
I think about those dudes I hung out
with him my mom died I was with him
every day for [__] two years every
day you know your kids age you know that
was my house he would always complaining
to his mama come here give him a bigger
piece of chicken to me what the [__]
and he'd go think about the [__]
situation okay let him get the bigger
piece of chicken yeah he got an ant that
lived in the back that was crazy so
she'd be back there watching Spanish
television swatting flies we just
giggled out of the deal we just giggle
with chicken go [__] yourself
but he just called me so it's nice
listen to some of the other guys man we
want our own [__] ways another guy
hit me up two weeks ago that was cool
with me and then when he got out of high
school he became an undercover cop and
[__] they started busting my friends
I didn't accept a friend request
[__] him [__] douchebag we were tight
he know what we were doing that's like
cheating and [__] you know what I'm
saying he busted my friends what type of
[__] guy does that [__]
well I had this friend that I met when I
was 19 who was a stripper and she was an
awesome stripper she had like the best
costume she would do theme shows she
would do you know that song Little Red
Riding Hood right she come out in a red
cape and have a little basket and give
everyone little chocolate kisses and and
we've had this friendship now for how
many years but sometimes we don't talk
for like three and five years because
she goes [__] crazy and she just does
crazy [__] but she's like my co-witness
in one of the most turbulent times of my
life so she always means a lot to me but
she sometimes doesn't understand how a
friendship should work
what's so funny
I don't know I'm laughing because I
gotta ask you a question okay ask me a
question
what's going on
a tough time sleeping you know what I'm
saying
sometimes I wake up alone like to pee
and I just don't get up
what does that mean I had to sleep with
the [__] Tower of pee inside of me
for two hours until I finally Gotta Give
In I do it all the time what a horrible
way to [__] sleep and live your
[__] life when you gotta beat and
you're like there's no way I'm gonna
[__] it I'm not getting up it's too cold
to get up
and you hold it for two hours that's
self-taught like most countries that's
disgusting and you get up and you gotta
pee and [__] no the worst is when you
have to fart oh no I let it out
and then it's not a fart I fought on the
plane it was so [__] bad it was that
Paducah meat the other day the guy next
to me was sleeping they went into his
nostrils [__] he was snoring tremendous
I love when they give up they give that
little [__]
[Laughter]
so I listen and I know these things
did you ever do that Felicia yeah
[Laughter]
you can't laugh you can't sneeze you
can't giggle one time my sister-in-law
she's got the flu and she's like I have
to sleep on the towel and I was giving
her
and then I got the flu from her and I
had to sleep on a towel
it's crazy though there's a comedian at
one point he's just started snapping her
girl snapped in New Jersey this weekend
yeah you see that oh yeah yeah yeah but
I don't think she did you snap or she
was just talking about what you want to
talk about
okay listen to me do you know what comes
out of my mouth at that [__] club
yeah
at a club I worked that [__] raw
that's my back [__] yard
do you understand me you have any
[__] idea I throw down at that club
because I can open the valve it's Jersey
I grew up there yeah I know all the
little intricacies the different pounds
I could say where they go to spring
break I know all that [__]
and I never [__] Had a Bad setting
there that's Savages
she said a rape joke I don't know what
the [__] happened last night I don't
know what the [__] happened
something must have [__] happened to
see the people go to see your sensitive
white people they're Gentiles and
sometimes he goes up they are they group
free they drink mochachinos Jersey too
oh they got them yeah oh those people
are spreading yeah all those [__]
people are spreading I'm happy you're
here I'm really happy you're here
because there's something I got to show
you Lisa yeah
I call Lisa yet today
I haven't seen this in years
you know listen I came from Cuba all I
ever wanted to be was a dirty white
person
that's all I have a lot of life
when I was about 13 I really got a
[__] taste of it my mom put music on
that bar and I heard this music and I'm
like wait a second
Morrison was dirty
put that poetry [__] didn't make them
that dirty that poetry should pull them
out like the end is strong but when I
heard the Allman Brothers Felicia some
about that that makes me go
ape [__] like especially so puts them on
for Felicia put on
all them brothers live from the Fillmore
East 9 29 1970 whipping post okay that's
gonna have to just put Whipping Post
Live From The Fillmore East
I want Felicia to see this one by the
way I saw this and with my I was in
Kansas with my family over Easter and my
stepmother was watching PBS but she was
watching a documentary about the sound
Studios and Muscle Shoals
it's such an amazing documentary that's
badass who went there and [__] yeah did
you watch Final last night I did when
you went to talk to Elvis oh yeah like
what we go to Muscle Shoals yeah and
Elvis is [__] foaming at the [__]
Mount yeah yeah yeah oh my God let me
blow my nose up yeah Lee if you get a
chance to watch this documentary it was
so amazing and then it was about how
Dwayne Allman came down and then he
brought his brothers but all the people
that recorded first one on top in those
Studios it's amazing
Aretha Franklin all the people
look at these two Savages and then we're
gonna fast forward this you know people
talk about singers
anybody could go up there and sing
but to lay your soul down two different
worlds hit it Lisa when I start from the
beginning just in the beginning we'll
fast forward it watch these Savages
[Applause]
see these guys didn't know they weren't
thinking about Trump
they weren't thinking about Republicans
they weren't thinking about black people
this band they were just thinking of
being white Brilliance this is all this
is this is white brilliance
[Music]
hello
listen to that guy's voice though
look at that boy's face yeah are you
[__] [__] Brad Pitt
[__] damn Michael Vincent Sons of
Anarchy look at his eyes what the [__]
you think is on his mind
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I know it's pretty amazing
so awesome
[Music]
we think he's talking about Zach I'm not
gonna [__] up that's what he's thinking
about white Brilliance Felicia yeah
these guys are a dirty town in Florida
or Jacksonville or one of those places
that look at this look this guy don't
know nobody except him he don't even
care about the memo yeah he don't have
time to [__] with the memo
do they have two drummers I think they
do right yeah I have two drummers
Brothers
who they like and they'll go you know
he's not he doesn't have a color they
didn't think that way these guys thought
about the soul of the music that's right
that's why in the documentary that was a
really one of the first times in those
Studios were blacks and whites work
together and they were talking about in
Muscle Shoals how they would come out of
the studios and there'd be white guys
and black guys and everyone would stare
at them just hanging out because it had
the connection
Wayne Allman came he was the first guy
that had the long hair and then people
really were like
they didn't look at color dog they
looked it
they didn't even see color these guys
they grew up in [__] we hate
brothersville look at this guy how many
joints you think he smoked today
[Music]
oh
this [__] this morning had me sweating
Felicia yeah pouring out of my armpits
my sides were swept I was drinking
coffee I was banging that [__] pipe
outside I watched this whole thing I was
like Jesus Christ
[Music]
okay
look look
effortlessly look how cool he is
[Music]
now I think that guy's Dicky best that's
the crazy guy that they all talk about
the one in the middle the guitar player
or is he a bass player a guitar player
these are just as lethal as this [__]
Savage right here
[Music]
oh I'm loving you
look at what you've done but nothing's a
chance the bad times
[Music]
foreign
why that really affects you oh this is
white Brilliance yeah this is something
that
didn't uh they didn't walk around with
their coffee cups they didn't care about
what you look at look at them look at
them they didn't care they cared about
them this is live it sounds like
and there's I don't know how many
[__] people there that's a big place
these guys were this will never happen
again
you don't think never again yeah they
don't appreciate it they don't
this is something completely different
they were going there little you think
those guys have a costume designer
did you see any hats did you see any of
that yeah yeah give me the [__]
guitar you really want it you know what
you're getting yourself into it by
coming here tonight yeah well I didn't
know we're gonna rock and you know suck
every you're ready that's what they did
look at the
they didn't [__] care
and I always say if the [__] they
wouldn't have died it would have been a
different game but these guys they're
[__] that's too much for me to even
watch that [__] makes me get the car
and just drive off a cliff because I
could never get that good
I could never be that free
really
that's even when you're on stage and
you're just talking some major [__] and
you're not even doing your act and
you're just free-flowing back those guys
tapped into something
not I could tap into something
but for you what you Lee and I that tap
into something together uh-huh
a different ball game
at the same time
[__] stage connecting yeah that's
perfectly that'll never happen again Led
Zeppelin at the Garden that'll never
happen again UFO Strangers of the night
that'll never happen again and you when
you have a great set is not at that
level
like well the best out of your life
listen man I dream to achieve that type
of perfection
that's what you dream of not one night
but to do that three out of five nights
on the road alcohol women
drugs freedom that's a big [__] word
and that's what those guys were
they didn't give a [__] they reached the
level to do that at the Fillmore East
you know they have all those songs watch
that whole thing
and you'll sit there and go what the
[__] out of these guys on it I'll do it
I'll do it what have they got give me
the exact Chinese powder they want and
who shot it
and what that's what I want that's
Perfection do you ever have a uh time in
your life where you did sets that were
so exceptional to you that you remember
it like for me I remember living in New
York and I did once it set at Joe's Pub
which was sometimes kind of a hard place
to work and I don't know how it happened
but I had one of the best sets that I'd
ever had and I still think about that
night how it was like lightning struck
for me do you ever have a set like that
that you think about
yeah
yeah yes and where was that at
last year on the road
last year on the road there would be a
couple cities I would go into it and I'd
have my [__] way
to the point where I couldn't believe it
like there were uh Ice House crowds
you weren't doing great you were
manhandling them like for 40 [__]
minutes you know like 46 minutes of man
handling them
when we taped the special in Vegas
that's special is kapoots because I
didn't manhandle them
the room was too big and my timing was
off I had to do too much time I felt
like I had dragged my material and get
my point across
it really wasn't my style I'm not good
at shooting [__] specials man I'm
gonna shoot the CDs I'm not really good
at specials for some reason why do you
think that is
I got like a mental block in my mind I
[__] fold two days before this
bachelor
really yeah I followed two days before
this special I just cave
it's too much yeah I I don't know I
always think that
ah name the three specials that [__]
inspired you
well for sure Richard Pryor live on
Sunset really yeah why uh because right
when I uh
Jeff Valdez when I was 19 years old I
lived with him and my dad came in to
Denver and my dad was projectionist and
he had to go his job is when the old
equipment was being replaced he would go
in and replace the old equipment and put
the new equipment in and take it with
him and he worked at a really old
theater where they he replaced the
equipment and it was a Richard Pryor's
live on Sunset that came on and that
changed my life and then I saw about a
year ago the documentary about Richard
Pryor doing that special and how the
first night when he did that special job
that was about the time at the Hollywood
Bowl we went then oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
when I needed your insurance right right
and and uh and then I mean like his ass
must have been sweating he was bombing
so hard and then he came back the next
night
and killed it
you know and I can relate as a comic to
that you know to uh and I think you
don't even have to be a comic to relate
to that you know something you're doing
at your job where you [__] up you know
and you know you got it and then you're
like I'm gonna [__] do it no matter
what and then you go back and you kill
it the next night so for that that's one
of my top specials that I think changed
my life in the beginning and then
changed my life
a year or two ago when I saw the
documentary I think it was a year ago
well I took the bus to go see that
special you did I took the bus on a
Friday night with Sabatino Dominic
special his older brother
we had to be 13 14 maybe 15 I guess
right something like that
we took the bus down there and I got my
arm cut
the way up they tried the Mungus in
Jersey City
but I remember going to see that special
being happy because he had recovered
from the burn and all that [__] but when
he did that joke I think I almost fell
down and there's many a nights that I've
sat there smoking weed thinking about
that night
thinking while I was watching that at
that early age in the back of my mind
was I really thinking about staying
there but I got looking and tell you the
truth and not at all
I thought it was brilliant well he had
done I [__] went home I had
Bicentennial [__] I had was it
something I said in fact today I went to
the doctor
elevated too the second floor the thing
opens up and all five acts walk on man
look at the one I go was this something
I said and that's the cover when it was
one album with the with the thing on and
there's a bunch of white people he's got
a mask on or they got hoods on or
something like that
when I heard that that really impacted
me yeah that really and again stand up
was nowhere close when I went to see
that guy from Boston
in uh 87 stand up was not even on the
[__] Horizon yeah nothing at all that
time
nothing I didn't even think about it
like that I didn't start thinking about
it seriously till
and I'd get on stage until 91. so that's
how long I dragged my [__] feet you
know
when I think of specials I think of that
one I think of Andrew's special
who's kind of Andrews the first one's
from Philadelphia Andrew Dice Clinton I
think of Eddie Murphy's delirious
and two nights before I'm doing my
special I came because in the back of my
mind they'll never be that good
that's what I want I want that type of
perfection that it happens
once in a lifetime but it lives forever
you know yeah in the back of my mind I
cave even though I'm going to I go on
the road four weeks and polish it and
cut [__] out and really tune up the
energy because that I gotta come out
once I come out at a GI I got them but I
gotta come on the first round like Rocky
Balboa I can't piss around and make
believe I'm Seinfeld once I think I'm
Seinfeld it's over I'm so surprised to
hear that yeah you help me a lot because
you told me once you are what you are
people come see you come see that type
of [__] and that nonsense and I I
understood it
I go she's right there's people I could
listen to there's people I could not
listen to and that's just the way life
is you know well conversely when I
started at The Comedy Store Richard
Pryor would come in and he would come in
on a Tuesday night and he would do a set
and you know uh that special changed my
life but then you fast forward 10 years
later or whatever and probably not 10
like five years later and he would come
in to the original room go up at 8 30 on
a Tuesday night and he would be so
[__] terrible and you as a young
comic you'd be sitting there going what
the [__] man this is supposed to be the
great prior but you're young you don't
know and then you would see him come in
every night and then like come in
Wednesday and maybe one joke would work
and by Friday night it would be like
[__] butter you know what I mean it
would be so amazing and you're like this
is the [__] great prior and he would
be killing it and that was a big lesson
to me me as a comedian that to see
someone who I revered so much to eat the
biggest [__] and not care not care
Chappelle does that I saw Chappelle do
that the other night you have to do that
you have to you have to do that that's
the tightrope yeah that's the tightrope
that's the discipline that's it until
you can do that nothing really moves
forward that's why what really helped me
was 98 at the store
I got involved in something up there
that was a sort of Storytelling and that
gives you patience when you saw the
storytell you got to be up there for a
minute or two weaving them so you got to
become interesting
that taught me the patience Lee hit it
let's do some shout outs here
Felicia's gonna go do a set and [__]
you're sitting there all [__] stoned
I'm happy you came by and [__] well
thank you for having me
oh no it's interesting
[Laughter]
God damn I've missed you Joey
right there
so I'm gonna go pick up the steroids
tomorrow
I gotta go on a four-week steroid plan
to reduce the swelling in my nose yo
what's going on with it
I had to answer a question and have you
got like four out of [__] seven
that's it so for four weeks I go on a
steroid thing reduces the swine I gotta
be off this by Friday yeah that stuff is
no good if you get addicted to it right
yeah now it's not even working almost
yeah when you pass
working out
because I get anxiety
so you're allowed to put one spray in
the morning and one nostril and one
spray and the other one every 12 hours
and if you're gonna just go wean
yourself off and just toughen it up for
the weekend like this I used to have an
uncle and a cousin who was addicted to
that nose spray and they would keep it
in their little pocket oh my God and
they would they would speaking of a guy
with a mirror always doing that right
with a spoon they would be every like
five to ten minutes they'd do a snort
snort the last couple weeks 10 days I've
been blasting one or two and I got it I
gotta blow my nose and then put my head
back and let it go in there
and I've been sleeping at night so
hopefully they're gonna put a balloon in
there in four weeks you know what I'm
saying Lee you are right over that a
little 200 package [__] kill you yeah
we're gonna do some shout out to you my
man Chris penny
Bob the link is hoping your dad's good
Joey Brooklyn looking good Hayden
Hurlburt Kyle Uber Travis Anderson rad
Jazz and my man Jesse Wright if you
[__] in the San Francisco
Oakland Bay Area this weekend's Felicia
Michaels is working at the I'm gonna be
actually being Reno Reno Reno at the
Silver Legacy Silver Legacy but it's the
factory in the silver I don't see no but
people will drive on the weekends no
they do they do they will they have
nothing going on they'll say you know
what [__] them let's take a ride to Reno
get [__] up watch Felicia Michaels
[__] blow the stage up at Marino and
[__] that's a good little place yeah I
can't wait I've never been there not to
that room I used to go up there when it
was a catch a rising star now a catch a
rising stars are they done I don't know
uh I think there's one in Jersey still
is it check it out Lisa
I am banned from there are you really me
and the kids from Philly the kid that
does the signs for the improvs hey you
don't talk
and he's from Philly
you were going to any of the improvs in
the beginning of the show a guy comes
out I know you're here
uh you came down to watch Comedy but
your cell phone shut up what's his name
Todd Glass Todd Glass Todd glasses from
Philadelphia and me and him are the only
two comedians banned from the whole
catcher right chain what did you do to
get banned I was working the week and
there was a snot
and at 5 30 they called me and they go
hey we're canceling the show
then at 7 30 it died snowing they called
me back and they go we on the show and I
was in the city
so I said guys I'm in the [__] City
I'll never make it you guys could do
this to me there's a snowstorm this
traffic
so I didn't show up they gave me my
check and [__] but then they just said
he's fine and he's
wow I was always working Reno Reno was
good yeah Reno is a fun place because
the machines were [__] broken so you
could always hit the jackpot for 1100
but then the Clinton there is the guy
that ran the [__] club was tight with
the floor manager so on Saturday they
let you go in the booth and they would
run the money for like 10 minutes and
you could catch money
gotta do what you got to do the cocaine
problem you know what I'm saying
every 10 count as soon as you get in the
old days as soon as you checked in they
gave you an envelope
as soon as you came in they gave you an
envelope a uh
coupons for the Chinese noodle bar and
the buffet not bad I went there with
what's the guy that died the Vietnam vet
Cuban Vince from The Comedy Store got
diabetes
towards the end the asian wife Nice Guy
did the CDs for everybody he did the
week with me I did it with Schubert one
week I was doing it a lot and they
[__] banned me but I was up there
twice a year up there the Silver Legacy
I would hit the jackpot for 900. and
then I would get three four five six
hundred in the [__] thing
and they gave you a measly 75 as check
you know it didn't do nothing for you
but who gives a [__] just them little
things you made though and the guy was
cool because
the assistant to the assistant to the
assistant to the assistant manager at
the club was also the manager at the
recording studio
so he would steal the dupes uh-huh who
does that [__] it was oh this is when
the Improv was here no this is one yeah
there was a kid that was a manager at
the comedy club in the daytime he worked
at the recording studio and bands would
go up there in the record and he would
put an extra tape recorder on you know
what I'm saying that he would pull him
out and give them to you as a gift
so when Aerosmith was up there
rehearsing he taped all the [__] with
her [__] like that right he was just a
dynamite kid he paid you on Friday
instead of seven you got your check
cashed right he was just one of those
guys and again that you think about and
go wow where is he you know like that
that's it that's
Lee you're 26 you're gonna make a
thousand friends
and you're gonna lose a thousand friends
and you're gonna sit there and go what
the [__] happened and now thank God
Facebook
thank God you have Facebook now because
now there's a slight connection to these
people if Felicia Michael gets bored one
night she goes what happened to that
open mic 1888 you could press a name in
and she'll come up on Facebook or not
and all of a sudden you'll realize they
live in some town in Tampa Florida and
she's got three kids or something that's
the power of Facebook that's what
Facebook you know 10 years ago was
classmates.com
I don't even remember classmates yeah
class they're still around lurking
trying to get a 20 from you though pink
remember your first crush in high school
give us 9.95 we'll see I get like 20
bucks nothing never happened nobody
[__] registers for class only Geeks
the [__] killers they don't you know
chronic acidorian the Charlie Gizzy he's
not gonna
classmate.com I think it still exists
yeah
[__] yeah classmates.com but ain't
nobody giving them 9.95 they got
Facebook now who gives a [__] what is it
how much is it to join I mean look and
find out this is the first time they've
even had advertising you I'll give it a
free [__] advertisement I forgot all
of that yeah they've been lurking on
Facebook you pop up from time to time
hey you want to bump into Mildred you
know what and pay you
I'm on Facebook talking to Milton's
brother right now I gotta give you 9.95
to join and [__] see pictures from
high school has there ever been an
experience where you've bumped into
somebody and you were like step back and
sneak away
whatever
any era
a lot of people show up to shows
it's really interesting
it really
I think about them I think about our
interaction like when they hit me on
Facebook or
they surprised me and I go hold on hold
on great to see it let me go take
pictures while I'm taking pictures of
people I'm thinking about our history
like why is he here you know
and sometimes I'm really happy to see
people
but sometimes I don't know it's kind of
weird like they I don't like how they
show up
you know especially when I go to Florida
when I go to Florida they come out of
the woodwork
and there's people that are really
Dynamite that I see that come up give me
a hug and they're like we gotta go bro
and I'm like yeah yeah but then there's
people that want to work there's one guy
Louis jirez Old School North Bergen
Knight comes up to the shows pays for
his own ticket
yo
and I'll see him and he'll come over
give me a hug and he'll just disappear
because he understands the situation
what's going on and stuff but nine out
of 10 times Felicia
[__] yeah I'm happy to see somebody
[__] yeah there's people that I want to
see that haven't popped their head up
that's what really kills me like
I did a lot of things with them you know
what I'm saying it's easy to get a hold
of me now I'm gonna [__] I'm on all
this [__] you know
but anybody from those days yeah I like
to have a conversation with them
from that rap battle now we thought we
were kind of crazy I don't talk to
stinky anymore
but I talked to his brother
I talked to his brother like once a
month we're still tight
he sends messages
at the end of the conversation
he always apologizes for his brother not
talking to me
and him and I don't talk
because he told me as a man he goes
listen
I'm really proud of you what you did man
but I I can't talk to you I mean he said
it to my face Felicia oh really on the
phone really nobody's ever done
something like that but why did he not
want to talk to you this was after uh
you know why Felicia
because as much as we loved each other
every time we'd see each other it was
never nothing good
and I came a [__] hair from ruining his
life we both could have got arrested for
robbing a jewelry store with Marblehead
and we both would have done 10 [__]
years all three of us
and I think that sometimes he thinks
about that and he goes what the [__]
every time I was with this [__] dude
I mean Felicia every time we had a good
time but he wasn't Innocent but in some
people's minds Felicia like my buddy
avillo told me one time that he actually
hooked up with Fernie
and that during the conversation for he
said you know I'm going to tell you
something my mom's really mad at you
and he goes what are you talking about
and she goes my mom's really mad at you
because of all the parties you had
growing up
and I always thought that the problems I
got into was because of you
that's a weird [__] angle to have on
life that you used to have a lot of
parties so I became [__] up because of
your parties
but I didn't talk to stinky from 93 and
I probably called him in 2001 I was in
Jersey and I was driving and I got his
number from a friend of mine I called
him up he answered the phone we talked
for like 15 minutes
and then he said listen man my life is
changing now
I got a kid I'm a morning and Christian
I don't drink yeah
I don't do this no more I don't do that
no more I just work
and he had got money
he had gotten a stock buyout like he
started at UPS and they used to pay
so he started ups and 82 dog
that's the only job he's ever had since
high school he started at UPS in 81. how
many years is that late
1916. that's a little 35. he's been at
UPS since he was
wow it's like in 2000 they did a stock
buyout they got like three million
dollars are you serious stop talking to
his brother for a few years because of
the dog stopped talking to a few of his
friends
so when I called him he was still on the
don't even think of me like on that
defense if you follow me
and I said damn you know it's good to
talk to you you know I always loved you
he goes I love you too he doesn't listen
he's the the truth
I changed my life blah blah blah so I
appreciate me lose my number
I didn't say [__] off or nothing I go
you know what thank you for the honesty
thank you for always being there for me
when I was a kid I understand
I didn't shed a tear because at least he
told me and people don't tell me that's
what it was he said it right out I was
like you know what man
and I thought about it I broke it down I
never did nothing bad to him in fact we
made dough together
but thinking back I took him down some
dark streets that he could have got out
of don't get me wrong there's no victims
in my [__] there's no victims here
yeah he could have said plenty of times
dog the same for me and guess what the
type of guy I am able to still taste to
give him a taste because I love them as
a brother we were together for a long
time we've done a lot of [__] together
there was a time you know Felicia I was
telling lithon I used to buy a thousand
black beauties
14 hours
Jesus you know what that's like the only
friends you have
a thousands because 40 a thousand
divided by 40. that's nothing that's
penny is a piece not even not even so if
you bought 10 heads of masculine from me
I'd throw them 10 [__] black beauties
and you go oh my God you're the best no
it cost me [__] 10 cents
to make so much fun of those black
beauties
he had a girlfriend that used to do them
and I used to give him a cut just
because he'd sell them like I give him
like 50 bucks a week when he was a
sophomore in his world
50 bucks was he could go to clubs you
know when he was 16 in those days you
went out at night
I would give him a cut he would call me
up and I'd say listen I sold this this
week take a cut oh yeah yeah I told this
guy to biops from me just because he was
helping me out a little bit I always
took care of him and when we were
robbing whether he held the gun or not I
gave him a taste you know
my brother's got the car was it a bigger
taste if he had a gun
the more action you're doing
you show up with the eyeball you get
more action if you show up and go listen
in that building on the third floor
there's a guy who's got a million
dollars up there what I'm gonna do is
this Joey I'm gonna catapult
up to the third floor I got a [__]
chain like Spider-Man I'm gonna pull
myself up going all I want you to do is
get a little walkie-talkie
I expect 300 G's
for a walkie-talkie why not
why not nothing working working it like
a professional how do you work
walkie-talkie you were out here with
your dog you know with a what they can
see your face if the cops pass by I'm on
the corner watching deep I got a [__]
CB radio in my ear with the cop [__]
thing so if somebody calls and says we
see a little Jew ball the guy going
across on a [__] catapult you
understand me I got the the the the
[__] police radio in my [__] ear
that's a CB guy
to keep my mouth shut
right or wrong right or wrong you want
me to go tell him something see if you
give me 100 Grand I'm gonna go home and
think about it and say he's a greedy
[__] what if
I tell my friends Lee has nine hundred
thousand now in this apartment right now
you're gonna last 15 [__] minutes
if I put it out there on the police
walkie-talkie you'll last 15 minutes
those gorillas will kick your [__]
door then throw you off the balcony how
would you get the word out back then oh
my God just go to the bar and sit there
and get a drink and go
oh at least got 900 000 in his apartment
can you believe that
suddenly there's no one in the bar but
you and people will look at each other
and go what are you talking about
[__] leaving me Rob that joint the
[__] you bastard give me 100 [__]
Grand they got a million cash 900 000.
that's it
you sure yeah where's he got the money
well we just robbed them 10 minutes ago
this has got to be in this house you're
dead
you're dead what people will do for 900
000 cash you're dead don't March right
in there with math they don't care about
cameras nothing they'll kick the door
down put a gun in your mouth go where's
the money you'll be negotiating I'll
give you 200 000. boom that's it it's
over they'll just take the [__] money
you might just give it to them Joey put
the word on but you give me 300 000.
it's honor to keep my master I'm not 100
to forget
remember that thing we did what thing I
don't know
that's it those are expensive thoughts
to forget Jesus 700 000 you're gonna
clear for [__] Bingo the Clown for 10
minutes who do you think's out there
working the walkie-talkie like a Savage
what if I just cut the [__] rope
and call the cops on you you're my
competition you fall off I go up there
and take the mill
you ever think about that no you didn't
so this is why you pay the small three
percent then everybody's happy you go to
an island I never see you again it's not
the small three percent the small 33
percent
where's the movie with Sean Penn
he did with his wife
the late 80s he was in the Irish mob
and he didn't like what he was saying so
how he got out was he he stayed with
John Turturro really good [__]
movement he stays the fake hit and he
disappeared to Boston and became a cop
that the guys with Gary Oldham oh yeah
what was that movie
and Ed Harris and [__] the blonde and
Robin Wright
State of
Grace's Meredith oh yeah they kick his
door down he's like I don't know nothing
I'm just eating [__] beans out of a
can I'm an old man I don't see nothing
he's in that [__] movie
but that was the plot with Sean Penn
that he had done something so that rep
that was still out there
so when he went back that's the first
thing that Harris made him do he was a
couple years ago you shot a guy up in
the Bronx you got to go up there and
show them up because he knows he gets
pinched for something he's gonna come
back where else oh I was watching
something else from Paducah yeah that I
was watching something with it anyway
who gives a [__] did you ever see
sicario yes I did that was a [__]
awesome movie she was very good she was
great in it she was very Venezia was
amazing in it and the other guy was good
I always liked him he's really good he
used to be married to that chick hot
looking guy older now with the
flip-flops on throughout the movie
American gangsters he was [__] good
dog Lee what's going on with you
speaking of the movies I went to the
drive-in this weekend it was so much fun
what was the name of the place yeah I
went to the one you were talking about
it's like uh the the Vineland Pacific
Theater or something but the it's
actually cool Pacific Theater seems to
have like a bunch of small theaters but
it was all it couldn't have been more
fun it's like an hour away and like a
crappy neighborhood or something like
City of Industry it's right by the train
tracks which kind of it's like the one
downside but it was cool like they had
it built like kind of like a a ski
slalom so we you could park the car tilt
it up and we had a clear shot of the uh
screen yeah it's on two movies we had
snacks we had all the food in our we
didn't leave the car once it was great
you had your own car no one was talking
you could be on your phone if you want
to
Paul it kind like if Paul wants to talk
during the movie she can talk and it
won't it's like a like ruin the theaters
it was pretty amazing when I was growing
up my dad owned a drive-in movie theater
in Stockton California and it had the
biggest screen in Northern California
and he lived on it this is so white
trash he lived on a trailer at the back
of the lot and he had a picture window
in his trailer and so you'd be eating
dinner and you would see like Orca
crashing into the period and our job
growing up uh mostly my brother's job
was to go and pick up all the garbage
and sometimes you'd find a lot of money
but mostly shitty diapers I was like the
worst job ever it was so terrible
yeah
the funny thing is every time you do a
gig you've seen that drive-in theater
somebody brought it to my attention
Somebody went down a date like 10 years
ago and she told me because I went down
a date and I think it was great
I wasn't really even on the five we took
the 10 a little bit down we took like
the 210 to the 10 sort of way
um but it was great the only just you
have to go and go see a movie that's
probably not like super serious because
the sound isn't great like I had to play
with my stereo to get it perfect but it
was it was nine bucks each
it was amazing it could have been more
fun when uh my first experience at a
movie was when I was really little my
parents went to a drive-in theater and
it was to go see the Yellow Submarine uh
The Beatles Yellow Submarine and I have
this memory of being like two years old
standing up in the back seat and
watching the movie and going what the
[__] is going on you know because it was
so such a crazy movie like I couldn't
understand like I should understand this
it's a cartoon I saw that movie yeah I
didn't know what the [__] I know all
right I didn't get movies so I went to
see her be the love bug and then I got a
little enthused about it and then I saw
like them uh the strongest man in the
world whatever it would jam Michael
Vincent was a Disney movie
and then after that I just dove into it
I went to see a James Bond movie and I
never went back to the kid movies like
all that [__] was [__] Snoopy right
once I Saw Her Majesty's Secret Service
I lost it and then my godfather took me
to see like either death wish or strong
killer
and I really lost it like that was it I
wasn't going back to Disney [__]
then I just got worse and worse like I
went to see The Exorcist in the movie
theater that makes it 10 years [__]
old that's not good yeah that's not
Bueno but I don't know before they
didn't care there was no PTSD you know
you should have PTSD after watching The
Exorcist 2010 there was another movie
that had come out about two years after
the Exorcist maybe about a year after
The Exorcist and what they did was they
tried to help do the Exorcist and they
gave you a puke bag oh
and it was like the Satan's tongue or
something something oh really and they
ripped out that was it they ripped out
some of these tongue in the movie or
something but then Midnight Express did
it and it was fine then by that time
they don't even edit that on ABC well
they don't show on ABC but I remember
midnight Expressions on ABC and they
didn't edit that part
wow you know it was on tonight Lee you
never discussed it with me you never
told me what you thought I am not big on
superhero movies okay I have never been
big on superhero movies but it was on
tonight and I had peace and I watched it
for an hour and I gotta tell you
something I cried that's why I love the
crow so much oh okay that is why the
crow listen I'm a sucker for a romantic
movie but not the good looking dude with
Sandra Bullock that's not a romantic
movie to me at all Rocky Balboa in the
first Rocky that's as romantic as it
gets he fell in love with a woman
changed her [__] every time I see
that movie it changes me more you know
then I was watching it before he goes to
the arena and the shorts and it doesn't
really matter and he goes back and he's
breaking down and she puts them together
they did that on one take that [__]
that walks around that people make fun
of and [__] and I watch Creed on the
plane
I was an Academy Award winner necro the
[__] black kid wasn't bad in Creed oh
no no he was really good
that's a [__] good act that's a good
looking dude dog that's gonna cause some
damage that's gonna be a really good
they shouldn't want to ask her so black
people shouldn't be pissed about that
Rocky
you know why he didn't win because the
people like that he's a joke but in my
world he's a hundred billion dollar joke
because he's he's laughing all the way
to the [__] bank with that goddamn
movie I saw that I saw Creed I had a
great time he [__] wrote Rocky
like Rocky's not a script there's so
many little intricacies in Rocky that
you look at and go that Momo wrote this
like he felt this during the like he
explained this to the direct like this
is what I really feel in this scene
let's do it just for him doing that I've
always given him the respect that man
[__] deserves she gone and asked I
don't know
they got me all [__] confused Felicia
but yeah the quote was it was
interesting it was very you didn't like
it no no tell me what you really [__]
thought I don't want you it's not a
great movie I I thought it was
interesting because it's like a very 90s
movie just like with the tones and like
the lighting and especially like the
like the like the synthesizer music in
it but it was
I I like I think I like it because like
when you're in love you see stuff in
like that when movies and stuff
it was a good movie
but it wasn't it never really took me
anywhere it was just it was fun watching
I was never really scared or I didn't
really know what to feel I was just
listening world how good was the [__]
that you came back from the dead to
Avenger yeah I thought the little girl
was feeling good [__] loved that
woman with all his heart and just to
think that a man could love a woman that
much how sad he was he came back to
Revenge and he [__] killed everybody
he scared the kid the kid's mom yeah
that was good when he took the heroin
out of her [__] arms when he kills
that dude uh
Luther
from 48 hours and all that [__] James
Patrick I did that movie with him The
Longest Yard Dynamite guy I loved that
because the guy kept saying there ain't
no coming back
there ain't no coming back there ain't
no coming back and he taped them up he
put a grenade in this [__] pocket no
that's tremendous scene he loved that
woman that [__] much he took the
other guy put him in the [__] tub and
chopped him up tremendous Nobody Does
this type of [__] no more you know what
I'm saying like you really gotta love it
he dug himself out of the Grave he had
the makeup
the music he had good actors in the
movie there was some [__] up dark [__]
in the movie and then to top it all off
he gets killed
he gets shot during that movie yeah with
a [__] gun from the set not one
charge was ever [__] oh he was oh
really nobody ever got charged nobody
ever went to jail for that I think I
think man in the movie he got shot so
what happened oh he got shot while he
was shooting that movie that's what
that's what you didn't know that I'm
trying to [__] was it because it was
a fake uh but it just weirdly it had a
ground in it and had like a thing that
had metals or went off like a bullet I
guess I don't remember the whole story
but nobody nobody ever got like this guy
died mysteriously got shot during that
[__] movie so did someone have to
else finish the role they used his face
you don't even see it
it was like three or four or five scenes
or something like that it was just the
weirdest [__] day
you know so dirt 20 30 years earlier
this happened with his father
it was an accidental death he went to
some woman's house took aspirins he
passed out and he [__] went into a
Coleman died and now this kid dies on
the set of this [__] movie it was
just you know and it wasn't a bad movie
I you know I watch it and I get amused
I've seen worse [__] it's not you know
it's not and I really like the little
girl so the little girl was very funny
um but do you have you seen a Felicia
um I saw it a long time ago but I was
just thinking about you know don't you
uh love when you get tricked into a
movie and you think oh it's going to be
the biggest piece of [__] and it kind of
is but then you it you identify with it
and for me and I'm excited to tell you
that part two is coming out did you ever
see the movie John Wick with Keanu
Reeves I I love that movie I really love
that movie did did you like that movie
I loved him
yeah I'm a piano
freak only two days and you can go to
Dukes any morning and there he is eating
breakfast right on Sunset next to
Whiskey
I used to go on every breakfast you're
coming every morning sit at the counter
you eat your breakfast go next door get
some weed at the wheat store that weed
store is still [__] there
on Sunset across from the penthouse door
where the penthouse door used to be that
Dukes yeah he's been there every morning
breakfast with a beard long hair
you don't even know his ham unless you
look at
I've always been a fan of that dude that
movie puts me over the top yeah the
shitty did in that movie yeah now in the
second movie they just shot it and
Higgin Machado who was on the podcast
was in that movie plays the cab driver
because he did all the [__] uh fight
scenes for the movie helped John Wick
the people who did that movie have a
studio in Culver City and all they do is
stunt men who do all that [__] all day
they do all the stunts for movies they
go out with the big movies like these
guys don't [__] around
did you also see that movie where he was
in where they uh he plays death or he uh
until the Swinton is in it and she plays
like the Angel Michael or uh they made a
show a TV show from it oh I hate that I
can't uh think of the name but I like
that movie too The Devil's Advocate is
badass the one with the [__] uh the
bank robber what the doodle died from
cancer God Rest his soul was tremendous
that they just did a remake
but somebody did about the bank robbers
that would dress up like [__] the
president oh Patrick Swayze yeah yes uh
I love [__] John Wick and whatever
the [__] his name is Keanu Reeves listen
man I'm really happy you [__] stuff I
know thanks for having me come by Joey I
always loved you I was never really mad
at you I always loved it yeah I always
thought we would talk it would just take
time
well thank you for saying that no I'm so
glad that uh we made up and by the way
you and your friend are gonna make up
maybe sometimes in Friendship there you
just take a break you know because
things are going down for different
people yeah and if it doesn't it doesn't
but it just yeah it was nice to hear
that things could
could change but just just go back for
one second about uh the crow
no because like Joey had me watch it and
I was like when I was watching I was
thinking how can Joey like this no no I
was thinking like why Joey likes it and
it was like
were you thinking about your mother or
like I was just trying to think of like
like I like this for two reasons I liked
it one
at that time
I think that movie came out in 93 4 94
and I was very upset about divorce
I was very very upset with myself
and I was very upset with myself
in the sense that
I didn't try to save the marriage
that where I came from you always try to
save the marriage you put everything on
where I came from the school that
thought I came from
early on the drugs and life and media
and everything else corrupted it
and at that time I was going through a
thing that I was beating myself up
because the reason why that happened was
because I didn't really love them you
following me and I was a [__] I was
beating myself up in the sense that
you know how can you not love somebody
so when I went to see that movie it made
me feel bad because
here I am 31 years old I never loved the
woman like he loved that [__] woman
like to come back out of a [__] grave
to kill somebody just even if it's
[__] right just right but you
identify with something like that just
that thought that you could love
somebody that [__] much
to the UK your soul cannot [__] rest
till you come out and hang those four
[__] just that thought and then
it's got my favorite thing Revenge
somebody who they [__] did something
wrong to he goes home he has a roast
beef sandwich
and he shows up and says remember me
because that's what it's all about one
time they're having a meeting
and it's creepy he was [__] his
sister
the dude with the sword and all that
dude he's a great actor I just saw him
this morning on Miami Vice
I swear to God that same [__] actor
from The Crow with the weird face he was
[__] the Asian sister oh yeah the
black dude was in the office and they're
beating up on that mobster dude that's
on all the movies at the pawn shop he's
really [__] gay great guy I love that
guy he plays a tough guy in all those
movies that guy that beating up on him
and that's what they're trying to figure
out who this guy is go see Eric draven's
grave and when he goes to see the grave
he sees he's missing
and they [__] wrap their head about
that but that's the two things a that
somebody could love somebody that much I
couldn't wrap my head around that and B
the Revenge angle
that he plot in all of them he set them
all up he took his time you're going
back to Man on Fire he took his time he
saw their weaknesses and he nailed him
he just nailed them one of the [__]
time and they couldn't believe it was
him
they could not believe it was him that's
what I really and it all goes back to
that Clint Eastwood movie
when he disappears and he builds the
shield
because he knows they're going to shoot
at his heart
and he comes on the guy keeps shooting
on his heart and he keeps falling down
and getting up
and finally after the third shot he
loses his [__] mind the clinics would
blast him he sucked him into his world
you follow me
it took his time slow methodically
I think you should go see Deadpool and
that's kind of what the movie's about I
think he really like it right not
knowing they throw him an acid and [__]
him up and he puts a superhero costume
uh it's not an acid he had he has cancer
why don't you [__] spoil it for
everybody
what the [__] is wrong with you in the
beginning
well I think that's why I like John Wick
so much and I know it's a stupid movie
but I really love the idea of that how
[__] up and he was this killer and
that he met this woman and that his love
for her was so strong he put his whole
[__] past behind him and then she
dies and then sends him a puppy from the
grave that's what gets me and then some
[__] kills the puppy he was more
pissed about that [__] puppy I
related to it yeah that's what got me by
three quarters of the movie he's killed
18 Russians and you're sitting there
going nowhere today
at the end of the day all this is
because of a [__] puppy
yeah I get that yeah like I [__] get
that dude like yeah you got that's it I
killed your [__] puppy what are you
[__] nuts yeah what are you [__]
thinking the whole Russian mob has to
come down oh yeah yeah he kills [__]
everybody that [__] puppy and [__]
everybody who kills a puppy and all this
would have done is a puppy with a
[__] box of chocolates and I'm sorry
everything was in touch listen we got
you a beautiful [__] dog what's wrong
with the dog beat the [__] out of my son
he's an [__] anyway you're doing me a
favor but we bro give him a dog
give him an envelope yeah we don't need
this war you're too dumb for this [__]
you don't need to come out of retirement
you don't need to [__] hit this fool
this Legend oh I was just thinking about
that when he hits the floor with the
sledgehammer it's like oh it's [__]
over for these people yeah let me uh
read this [__] sponsor and we'll get
the [__] out of here as usual on it I
love you guys sent me a package today
some shroom Tech some tea yeah booster
some Alpha Brain the new liquid the new
uh Doses and we hooked my man lee up
with some protein powder leaves going to
kettlebells three days a week he's
really committed to this thing so he's
gonna do a protein shake after his
workout to help him and we're going to
talk to you about the the new uh Mike
Dolce protein powder yeah it looks
really good almond it's almond banana it
looks [__] beautiful I haven't
snuffed I didn't want to open up the bag
I don't want you to walk around thinking
like Cosby so I didn't open up your bag
somewhere
somewhere Joey D is put a sleeping pill
in my protein
so no I didn't want to go in your pro
just tell me what you think you know
what I'm saying you may like it I like
the the hemp Force protein but anyway
let's cut the basics go to honor.com if
you see any supplements you like just
read about them I can sit here for
[__] hours and bore you to death
before I [__] around go to honor impress
in the code word church
I get 10 off c-h-u-r-c-h
IGN on it.com also I want to welcome a
new sponsor let me ask you something
people what the [__] do you think we
live here you think we live in Beverly
Hills now
when I'm in the suburb close to a place
called North Hollywood okay
if you drive around North Hollywood or
you see it
massage ball is mattress stores weed
stores and tattoo stores
and I'm talking the emphasis on mattress
stores have you gone shopping for a man
just in North Hollywood yet I just
bought a mattress in North Hollywood and
most of the pain he is it was a complete
pain in the ass what'd you drop uh it
was about 500 that's not [__] bad and
as the mattress comfortable is it yours
I don't believe this [__] it was for the
boys okay so [__] it but for one of the
boys it cost you a nickel LaRue for a
single bed or a double it was a
full-size bed a full-size bed for the
skinny one what's in a full-size bed
we're gonna put them in a little skinny
one and a full-size bed Marine style
like a TP and then sure I'm trying to
buy my daughter a [__] teepee
I sent her on a simple Mission she came
back with a thousand stories about this
one's too big this one's too small damn
it just buy the [__] dead how
difficult is it to buy a tent well how
do you know because with Diaz is we love
being in holes we're like Vietnamese
people on the other side we love being
hidden when you go in the baby's room at
night there's blankets and teddy bears
the teddy bear Steve Simone gave she
puts it on top of her head you know
oh really yeah she's like a Diaz she
covers herself up you know you don't
know how lucky I am I have the sleep
apnea machine you come into my room all
you see is a hose come on come under the
mattress looks like an armadillo or you
can sleep under the mattress under the
blankets oh no that's too much the air
goes down to zero and I put the blankets
over my [__] head and I go to nappy
Nunu time and all you see is the hole
you know how long I've been doing that
when I was a kid I used to make like a
little tunnel around my mouth and [__]
and just
like that I love all that [__] but I
can't breathe when I'm under the
blankets and you have trouble and you
can't breathe that's perfect that's what
knocks you out eventually you passed
it's like half suicide you know what I'm
saying it's like sit in the garage
without the hose you just sit there with
the fumes and you open up a window you
don't die you just sit there and get
dizzy
anyway the point being you're unique you
don't walk like everybody else you don't
talk like everyone and you don't sleep
like everyone so why is your mattresses
one size fits all now you people think
like we [__] around here in the church
I got a guy who calls me up and he sends
me [__] every week Felicia they they got
people sponsoring [__] now that you
can't believe and they sent it to me and
I look at half the stuff and I go I
can't talk about this [__] I can't even
mention them it's so ridiculous you know
and I try to run them by Lee and we
giggle sometimes that's nothing for my
attorney he just says no but sometimes I
go you know what I want to buy a [__]
mattress and it was a pain in the ass it
really [__] is a pain in the ass
except for that one place across from
Bank of America on Lankershim they don't
[__] around that dude and he delivers
the next day he don't [__] around but
again you got to go in and you don't
even finagle him you just tell them what
you want to pay for and he'll point you
to the mattress give them three days
he'll pick it up you know what I'm
talking about right across he wasn't
back if you go to that place in North
Hollywood then it's a [__] piece of
[__] then you get robbed up there they
hide behind the curtains
you go in there sometimes they're not
there anyway
I'm not here to talk [__] about anybody
but when I read about the Helix mattress
I [__] died I was like this
sounds perfect because I'm married I
know what it's like I like my bed one
way and Terry likes to deal with
somewhere along the line we came to
terms but my side's getting a little
swapped so I tried to flip it and she
caught me
she was doing laundry and I flipped that
[__] but she knew something a
pee stained something she knew
but anyway you're unique you don't walk
like everybody you don't talk like
everybody you don't sleep like everybody
so is it why is your mattress one size
fits all because a custom mattress will
cost you five to ten thousand bucks
until now introducing the Helix sleep
when you could buy a mattress online
customize for you for hundreds of
dollars instead of thousands you go to
helixsleep.com you answer a few simple
questions based on four key preferences
and the result will be a custom sleep
profile used to build you in the most
comfortable mattress you'll ever ever
sleep on your mattress will arrive at
your door in about a week and shipping
is a hundred percent free on the yarn
and for couples Helix customizes each
side of the mattress
so Paula sleeps over they can put a
better Nails on that side you understand
me and you can sleep on the [__] nice
side they can do whatever you want no
I'm just kidding no no that's me because
we're going to be moving in together so
we're gonna need a new mattress that's
right so here you go yeah Helix
customers report a 30 Improvement in
overall Sleep Quality you have 100
nights to try it out and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you 100 refunds no questions asked
that's why everyone's from GQ to Forbes
all talking about the Helix sleep do me
a favor go to helixsleep.com Joey you
get 50 off your order fifty dollars I'm
sorry fifty dollars off your order
that's helixsleep.com Joey
helixsleep.com Joey and you get fifty
dollars off your order again it's a
[__] painy ass this is the future
people nobody's gonna leave the house
with dick if they're any [__] got a
smart a brand ad look at last year sales
are down over the holidays Amazon's
controllers this is it you're going to
be able to [__] buy anything online
from now on free [__] shipping you
don't have to worry about delivery
they're gonna show from tens to two then
the truck broke down and [__] uh
laombra and you gotta wait there all
[__] day why is my mattress in
[__] Alhambra I born in North
Hollywood [__] anyway these days
are over do me a favor go to
helixsleep.com right now slash Joey and
get fifty dollars off your order all
right that's helixsleep.com Joey that's
right right now helixsleep.com Joey
fifty dollars and you're gonna sleep
like a [__] angel every night all
right I want to thank on it I want to
thank our new sponsor Helix sleep I want
to thank Felicia stopping by do not
forget you're there what nights break it
down I'm there uh tomorrow uh till
Sunday yes
that's a long [__] week well it was
nice today talking about Trump and how
the FBI can hold them so I had to drop
knowledge on you [__] you guys
don't know how to do it it's not called
black man only
it's letting you know I know what you
did [__] I ain't gonna say that
nobody
you're walking talking is worth that
seems like a little steep but okay a
walkie-talkie let's say you put Paul out
there right she'll save you some money
but that's the pain in the ass now she's
gonna want 600 000. how did she get six
now because she's Paula she's got the
power that you ain't got a muffler and a
monkey and you can rub it on your face
you understand me so you'll take the
short 40 percent
for the walkie-talkie but if you get
busted she'll roll over on you
you follow him say anything because
she's not gonna take the fall fee out
there she doesn't know about police
scanners and [__] like that like I know
and I'll find out I have every [__]
police scanner from North Hollywood The
Studio City to [__] Hollywood why
I'll be out there with the scanner
working I make believe I'm listening to
an iPod doing jumping jack but I'm
paying attention I got the walkie-talkie
like like [__] uh uh whatever you're
doing fine Lee
you're doing fine Lee there's a lady
walking down here with a dog you're
doing fine
and you're like I got in anything
nothing you got 38 seconds I'm
downstairs count it down for you got 37
seconds 36
where is he and he's in the apartment
laying down with a broad shoot him both
just shoot him boat the money's right
down to the matches
you shoot him you come back out the
alarm gets triggered you get back onto
like James Bonds
right here to the roof I am Buckley
we light the [__] thing on fire
what what things on fire now the Rope
okay
God knows what they blame it on you know
what I'm saying
I got the car parked I got a stolen car
already parked gas we're gonna go three
or four blocks we're gonna go by the
7-Eleven where the lady got stabbed
we're gonna park it right there then
we're gonna walk through it three blocks
and we're gonna [__] and that's it I'm
gonna split up the money we're gonna
shake hands I've never seen Lee this
high before
this is what we do what happens to the
poor lady
someday some dude goes in there one in
the morning they got no [__] Reese's
Pieces you think is the Isis I know
they're Isis that's why there was a
stabbing in there
I've known their Isis for years I just
don't tell nobody I'm not a rat I'm not
a punk [__] you know what I'm saying
Felicia Michaels Reno I'll be at the
Brea Improv all weekend Thursday Friday
and Saturday tickets are still available
I love you [__] see you
Wednesday night have a great day stay
black hit it Lee